you could spend ten thousand dollars on
a pair of trainers it's not going to
make you land with a tripod landing it's
not going to make you leave the ground
correctly we can't buy our way out of
trouble it's i think it's easier to
order something and for it to turn up on
the doorstep and we put them on and it's
a magic pair of trainers and now all our
troubles are solved we'd rather do that
and spend 12 weeks learning to move
differently
shane benzie welcome to the show
thank you for the invite
you were just in portugal tell me what
you were doing i was just in portugal so
i was in a place called nazareth and
nazareth uh has the biggest waves in the
world so it's on the atlantic coast and
uh it has huge waves and i'm
predominantly a running coach but
actually more and more i'm becoming a
movement coach with different sports and
i'm actually working on a project out
there studying and coaching some of the
big wave surfers so these guys are
surfing waves up to sort of 70 80 feet
so i'm really get excited about you know
their foot contacts on the board how are
they balancing on that board you know
what are they doing what's their
perception of their movement their
mental approach to something that's
pretty dangerous and that you can't just
go out every day and practice because
these big waves only come sometimes so i
use very clever sensors to put in their
boots to kind of have a look at how
they're interacting with the board and
all sorts of stuff and that does believe
it or not feedback into running
what is the similarity between surfing
and running
so
for me if i'm coaching running
one of the big things i get excited
about with running is the foot the you
know the human foot is a very very
clever thing and i like to think of the
foot as the interface between us and the
ground yeah if the foot lands well and
if the foot leaves the ground well when
we run it creates stability it creates
elasticity it creates amazing
proprioception from the quarter of a
million nerves on the bottom of it it
spreads impacts it does loads of amazing
things so if i can understand how the
foot interacts with lots of other
surfaces
and in other sports then i can learn
some very interesting things about maybe
how we should land the foot and leave
the ground when we run
what are some of the things that you've
learned since working with these
psychopathic surfers
well and one of the other big things
about sport as well is the mental
approach you know that that's that's
extremely important so we're learning
all the time about the foot the i when
i'm looking at foot contact in whatever
sport it is i'm always looking where
possible for what i would call a tripod
contact with the board or with the
ground or whatever it is you're working
with so i'm learning from them about how
they create stability in what is a very
kind of dynamic situation and how that
foot changes based on their interaction
with the board and maybe then i can
understand how better we should change
and interact our foot as we move move
over maybe uneven surfaces or uphills or
downhills because of course they're they
are on uh you know they're up going at
some pretty crazy angles so yeah lots to
learn and lots of information to swap i
did a similar well something similar i
had a have a collaboration with british
diving um so worked with british diving
in the lead up for the olympics
and
just looking at how the divers have
their their movement on the board not
the twirly stuff that's all really
exciting and impressive but i just work
with them on their three steps on the
board and then how they leave the board
so looking at things in my new detail
that then may be bringing them back into
running something we might do tens of
thousands of times in a single run what
about fear what did you learn to do with
the mindset of these guys they're
running they're swimming out to go down
these
60 70 80 foot waves how are they coping
with the nerves and anxiety before
enduring and keeping themselves in the
zone
well i think i think for sports you know
for athletes and i think when i say
athlete i think that's anybody who does
sport i mean anybody who does anything
athletic is an athlete i think with
athletes i think uh fear excitement
being nervous i think they're actually
good things because that produces
adrenaline and that gets us maybe in the
place that we need to be so i think they
are good things
i think what the surfers do a lot of and
what i try and get my athletes to do is
a huge amount of visualization so when
they come to surf a big wave they
visualize that wave many times and they
visualize what they're going to do on
that wave many many times so they don't
try and sort of ward off that that
nervousness or that fear because you
need a healthy respect for the ocean um
but yeah they channel it so that it
produces adrenaline that goes in the
right way
their ability yeah to visualize what's
what's going to happen and how to deal
with it i have a friend bridget fettesey
who's a comedian and she has a little
mantra before she goes on stage every
time that she goes on stage gets
butterflies in the stomach and her palms
get sweaty and her heart rate increases
she just keeps telling herself i'm not
nervous i'm excited i'm not nervous i'm
excited i'm not nervous i'm excited and
i use that i've done a couple of big
things recently and uh i'm not nervous
i'm excited it is a really [ __ ] good
mantra
because the difference between being
nervous and being excited really is just
the framing that you put around it
physiologically it manifests in a pretty
similar way yeah i would agree and you
know but coming up coming on the show
today you know there's that minute
before you're about to sort of hit that
button and come on you're thinking okay
and i think what i do and i think what
what's good for sport as well is if you
get that initial minute right if you get
that first minute right if you're
confident about how you approach and
then you've started in control then you
adapt to where it goes so someone might
shock you a tricky question and then you
you'll deal with that but if you start
in control and if you feel in control i
think that's good and i guess that's
what the surfers are doing when you know
when they when they're towed onto that
wave by the jet ski i think they're
thinking right you know i've done this a
thousand times this is what we do this
is how i'm this is how i'm entering the
wave and i'll now deal with the wave in
the way that i have to deal with it but
if you start in control i think that's a
that's the best you can do what do
people mean when they call you the
indiana jones of running
yeah so so my work really is i you know
i literally do travel all over the world
um to chase
chasing human movement that's kind of
what i'm doing because you know if i if
i if i watch a runner run or if i
analyze a runner or i'm coaching a
runner i'm coaching a human
you know about the human species i'm
coaching
an animal if you were and so i travel
all over the world
trying to track down what is good human
movement and i trace athletes all around
the world to lots of different
environments often extreme environments
like jungle
arctic
high mountains
amazon jungle rainforest to understand
how they adapt to these uh
extreme environments but i also spend a
lot of time with tribes and indigenous
people as well people who do incredible
things with their bodies but aren't
necessarily race wearing a race number
but
things i might go and live with the
sherpas who will carry twice their body
weight all day
you know or go and go and live with the
batek tribe in the malaysian rainforest
so amazing tree climbers how are they
doing that so humans are incredibly good
at adapting their software their brains
and their hardware their body to
different tasks around the world to suit
their environment
but isn't that what an athlete's doing
an athlete is adapting their body to a
specific task
so the more i can understand a what is
good human movement and b how to adapt
that human movement to a specific task i
think the better coach i can be so i
think that's where the indiana jones
thing has come from is because i'm just
constantly chasing this thing around the
planet that uh yeah it is the hope it's
that that holy grail of what is human
movement and how to adapt it and
coaching
yeah it's interesting to talk about it
being a a lost art i i'm not so sure
what you mean by being a lost art we've
just had someone run a sub two-hour
marathon it doesn't seem like running is
that much of a lost art to me
sure well actually i was there when when
kipchoge did it in vienna i was i was
there for the for the sub too um and so
i mean he's a he's a good example so
you know
he
ellwood kichobe didn't run a sub 2
marathon because he
ran like a hunter-gatherer he ran a
sub-2 matter because he harnessed all of
the gifts that mother nature gave him as
a running species and then he maximized
as much potential as he could out of his
software his brain and his hardware yeah
he turned it into human performance but
because the invite the environment that
you and i live in is not the natural
environment that humans grew up in so
for before i was working before i was
studying human movement i was working
with sharks okay so sharks so i did
stuff with great white sharks so great
white sharks have been around for about
400 million years and their environment
hasn't really changed over that time you
know they just swim around have baby
sharks and need seals
yeah yeah exactly so nothing's really
changed for them in 400 million years so
they've got amazingly good at swimming
around in a very efficient way and
living in an efficient way
for us for us as humans you know that's
really not the case we've been around in
a blink of an eyelid of that time and in
that time we've gone from
hunter-gatherers
to farmers
we've gone through the industrial
revolution and now the technological
revolution so we're actually like a fish
out of water really now you know we we
don't we no longer
live in an environment that we were
designed to live in and so because of
that we're adapting what we do to our
new environment so
it is a lost art movement is becoming a
lost art because we're no longer the
animal that we were so we're no longer
moving in that way
and what's really fascinating is if you
were to go out this afternoon and run
around it's
eight in new york city i'm not going out
there and running around
well you'd have to run just to stay
alive precisely yeah that's
if you ran around central park your
movement would actually be based on two
big things there are many things but the
two big things are
the environment that you spend your day
in so you're sitting at the moment so if
you spend a lot of your day sitting
your skeleton is essentially
free-flowing in a sea of tension it's
206 bones that don't touch each other
they just sit in an elastic sea of
tension and that sea of tension in your
body is created during the day when
you're static you then take that out
into dynamic movement so if you run
around in central park you're actually
going to be running with the sea of
tension in your body that you've created
for the other 23 hours of the day
the second big challenge for us is that
our movement is based on our perception
of our movement yeah and i think well i
have no perception i just run i just go
out for a run i have no perception we
all do even if it's a subliminal
perception and our subliminal perception
of our movement is one that's based on
the traditional view of biomechanics
which makes us feel mechanical the clue
is almost in the wood we makes us feel
like we're moving as a series of levers
and our skeleton is a structure so we
move in a block-like mechanical way but
actually that's not the case at all but
because of our new environment we sit a
lot and we're static a lot and because
of our new environment we are educated
about our movement in a way that's based
on biomechanics which makes us feel
mechanical so those two things
are creating a world that means that our
movement is almost becoming like a lost
language
it's changing because our environment
and it's getting harder and harder for
me to have to go further and further
afield to find people that aren't
looking down into mobile phones and that
aren't sitting yeah even in the last
decade that's become much harder
hmm
you have gone and studied a bunch of
different
groups looking at their movement looking
at how they
move themselves through and not all of
them were runners right so the sherpas i
think you tried to get them to run and
and basically they weren't they weren't
particularly fantastic at running but
they're very very good at strong uh
heavy carries two times their body
weight and stuff like that
of all of the people that you studied
who had the most beautiful running form
naturally
so the east africans i think i thought
you know
you'd have to go a long way to beat the
the ethiopians and the kenyans and i
think for me mainly the kenyans i think
they move
beautifully what is it how would you
characterize the way that they move
they move with a lot of
height in their body it's elegant yeah
it's elegant they move with elegance so
this sea of tension if i'm just going to
show you this so this is a kind of it's
a child's toy okay but it's actually a
10 secretary model okay now the concept
of tensegrity or biotensegrity for you
as a human is as i said earlier the 206
bones that are your skeleton are
free-flowing in a sea of tension so this
child's toy kind of tells that story the
wooden dowels are your bones yeah and
the plastic stuff that holds the toy
together are your tendons and your
ligaments and something called myofascia
so actually when you move your skeleton
it just free flows in a sea of
elasticity and that elastic tension is
created by your fascial system so if you
get beautifully tall in your movement
when you move you move with a lot of
elastic recoil you have connective
tissue that runs from your toes
continuously right up into your skull
now when the east africans run they run
with beautiful height in their body so
they really load that elastic system and
they do that beautifully
but you know what's really fascinating
and what i think is is really exciting
as well is that
when you watch
the
world record holders that i've been
lucky to spend time with you know they
move beautifully but if i was to ask
them to list the top 10 things that uh
may what made them think they were great
runners they would put movement pretty
much at the bottom
which is a little bit disconcerting for
me because i'm a movement coach
you know the reason why they put it at
the bottom
is because they don't know they learnt
it because they learn it by running in
the group
so by flow by the power of the group by
osmosis by being surrounded by beautiful
movement they start to move in that same
way it isn't coached as a technical
skill they just join in with the group
they mimic
yes well i had a
guy that wrote a book about rene gerard
who you know
his entire thing was this mimetic desire
and he saw it as a social phenomenon
that we want what other people want to
want and then we presume that that's
what we want so are you saying that
there is an equivalent here but
biomechanically that we see other people
around us we mimic the way that they
move and that becomes a part of i
remember when i was playing cricket you
know growing up and you'd see one of the
lads that was a quicker bowler than you
or a better batsman than you or a better
thrower than you
and you'd try and pick a part or at
least i would try and pick apart the
little things that they did presuming
that there must be some component of
their movement which is contributing to
these effective outcomes and um it makes
sense and i suppose as well in that way
that
you don't need to break it down
biomechanically if you have effective
runners in the group and you run with
the group and you watch the group then
you become an effective runner as a
byproduct of being there
completely and it becomes your default
much easier because it wasn't a learned
skill so when you're running so hard and
trying so hard that you don't even know
your own name your default is going to
be relaxation and beautiful movement
because that that's how you learned it
by running in the group we could learn a
lot from that we are huge amounts is
there a um
is there an implication here that the
people who are training and running
especially
as youngsters
that you want to get them into a group
with other high caliber very very
precise movers
completely absolutely and again i think
it's one of the things that certainly in
the uk that we don't do so well and you
know and it is a challenge because if
you had three groups of runners and you
were going to take them running it makes
sense for the fast runners to run
together they're not so fast and then
they're pretty slow um but it means
they're pretty slow never get to mimic
the front sight precisely you end up
with this sort of them and scenario
where it starts to split out yeah but
what the east africans do which is
ingenious is the so they have the same
problem because boy they got some very
very fast runners and some fast runners
and not quite so fast so everything's at
upper level but there are different
speeds but they do this very clever
thing where they will have a grid system
so take you think of something four
times like maybe four soccer fields the
size of four soccer fields and they will
have the runners running but it's it's
in diagonals across these football
fields obviously make the size of these
soccer fields so they run in diagonals
so you are constantly running past world
record holders you're constantly then
running behind them then towards them
you're always moving in different angles
across these pitches but you never leave
the best runners in the world even
though you're a complete beginner
and that's why they've done it is that
one of the reasons they've said that
they've done it to get people around
these beautiful reform guys yeah so they
can see each other moving and also it's
easier for the coaches to be in the
middle of those diagonals and watch
everything that's going on nobody really
disappears oh yeah of course because you
don't actually have to go all that far
away but you can still run a far
distance that's really really clever it
is it's it's ingenious you can have you
know sometimes you can have as much
sport science as you like and you know
in as much funding as you like but
sometimes just the simple things are
really really helpful
sun's matchbox cars track setup and just
duplicate that for a running method yeah
yeah it it's really it works amazingly
well and you know people maybe listening
to the podcast might be able to kind of
relate to this if you do a marathon or a
half marathon sometimes it's an out in
the back and as you're still going out
the fast ones are coming back and for
that fleeting moment you see them and
you think wow look at them well that's
amazing you get to see them for two
hours just constantly weaving in and out
very it's a great thing and we could i
think we can learn a lot from that so if
that's the kenyans and they're the best
runners on the planet talk to me about
the sherpas because they're strong guys
nims purger who did the
uh 14 peaks challenge he uh he was on
the show a little while ago and he's a
complete freak too
yeah yeah uh yeah they're incredible i
mean and this is so i i'd been to nepal
i used to climb
and i'd been to nepal maybe 25 years ago
um and was in complete war of the
sherpas but wasn't a coach or a movement
coach um just thought they were amazing
people but then when i started to become
a movement coach and started to think
right okay well what is what is strength
you know what is strength i think we in
the western world see our strength as
muscle yeah if you're talking about
strength we tend to think of muscle
strength
but i don't i don't see that i think
that it comes from actually a symbiotic
relationship between bone muscle and
fascia that like that children's toy it
creates that sea of tension
just like i thought right okay well
where do i think the best runners in the
world are where are the strongest people
where where are the strongest people and
i'd seen when i was in in nepal 25 years
ago sherpas carrying almost comical
loads it was just absurd where you could
barely just see a little pair of legs
and just this huge load to the point
where it looked like something out of a
soon and i thought right i'm going back
i'm going to study it and i've found an
amazing guy
and uh he allowed me to come to his
village he's a very remote village you
can only trek in and and i stayed in the
village and uh the sherpas there were
there were three everest summiters in in
the village and the the
back well back because it was off the
climbing season so i think there's like
24 summits between them and uh and and
was also spending time in the sherpa
community trying to understand and crack
this code of why they are so strong and
yet actually pretty slight and certainly
not muscular to look at
and also why would they carry everything
around their head
when all the smart people are carrying
big weights over their shoulders you
would think
so hey why can they carry weights that
we couldn't even look at and why are
they suspending them around their
forehead
that's why would they do that i found
that really really interesting
and if we can learn i thought right if i
can learn why they can do that then
that's going to give me some really good
ideas about how maybe
runners can run with small packs on
their back or
the military as well um and obviously
carrying weight and stuff like that is
obviously pretty important
so so i went out to live with the
sherpas and to study them and to
understand them
studying the power of the group as well
which i would love to talk to you about
i think that's massive it's everything
actually um so studying the power of the
group and also how they move and they
really did show me that actually it
isn't muscle strength at all it is this
symbiotic relationship between bone
muscle and fascia that doesn't just
create an elastic body yeah very strong
body
and this continuous
elastic tissue that runs from our toes
continuously up our body actually
finishes in
our skull in the top of our head
and that's why they carry the weights
around the forehead because if you hang
something off your shoulders you've
actually cut off the last link of your
strength an elastic chain
by suspending something around your head
you incorporate every single
part of the chain
presumably they don't know or they
haven't broken down the biomechanics of
how the facial system works what they've
done is they've tried it on their
shoulders they've tried it in their hand
they've tried it around their waist
they've tried it attached to their knees
dragging it behind them and they've
ended up saying look it would appear so
it's just an evolution of what was most
effective
absolutely and if you travel around the
world
and go to the math more far-flung places
people are carrying things either around
their head or on their head yeah yeah
well you see that with um
ladies carrying water for the tribes
right you know going to whatever the
local well is and then carrying it back
on top of their heads yeah it's so
interesting when you see
taking the approach that you have is
somebody that does the the sport science
you know real technical analysis of
running movement and so on and so forth
but then when you go and you just look
at evolution of what was effective
what was it that people did who are good
at this thing
what are they doing how can we then
repurpose that so we're having to
re-engineer our own movement in this way
yeah yeah i think i i think it's the way
because you know a human
six million years ago
we would have been quadruped so we would
have been on all fours and very muscular
with a lot of muscle and we wouldn't
have moved really very far we'd have
probably moved around about the size of
those four soccer fields why did we need
uh why do we need so much muscle
why do we need so much muscle well i
think it's a good point i don't know
because if you were uh if you were a
primate you wouldn't actually need to
have a huge amount of muscle to to get
your food
carrying stuff no but then i guess if
you're competing for a mate it probably
helps to be pretty strong and really
evolution is about you know the
strongest or the fittest or the most
able to to reproduce passes on their
genes so i guess through evolution the
stronger you were the more able you were
able to get a mate well one thing could
be that the
the muscle size is less a function and
more a signal
it's not that you're actually concerned
about what the muscles can do it's that
these muscles are almost like um
everybody knowing that you've got some
nukes in the arsenal you don't
necessarily need to even use them but if
you didn't have them they wouldn't work
as a deterrent and if you're looking to
signal i am a strong and capable
provider to my family
and i mean i've heard some stories about
two or three chimps can quite easily rip
another chimp limb from limb oh they do
it yeah yeah that absolutely i mean it's
a pretty disturbing sight and i think
it's a disturbing sight because we kind
of relate ourselves quite with us not
long ago yeah absolutely it can be quite
a disturbing thing to
see
but we took a different so we would have
been six million years ago those
quadrupeds and quite muscular and really
not moving very far off those four
soccer pitches and then we did
two things we developed a very clever
foot
and we developed the ability to stand
tall and get elastic
that meant we could cover more ground
with more efficiency catch more food get
bigger brains
get a space program now
i'm not saying we've been more
successful than the primate but a
human's usp is a very clever foot and
the ability to stand tall and get
elastic and dynamic and efficient so
when it comes to playing sport
if your sport allows it we should get as
much height in that body as we can
because that's a human's usp
given the fact that the sherpas aren't
jacked out of their minds bodybuilder
style guys
what have you learned is
what is the function of strength or what
sorry what is the contributing
elements to strength you know if the
bodybuilder or the power lifter or the
crossfitter isn't the person that can
carry the most
weight per kilo of body mass it's the
sherpa what is it that they're doing
where is their strength coming from
so
so it's a good question so
strength and conditioning is huge at the
moment yeah there's a lot of strength
and conditioning in sports and let's
let's say we were coaching running yeah
let's say we were talking about coaching
running here if i went to the gym and i
did a lot of squats and lunges and we're
lifting weights in the gym to get strong
really i'm getting strong at lunging and
squatting and i'm getting strong at
lifting weights
it's not really taking into account the
deceleration as i hit the ground when i
run it's not really taking into account
the impact that i create when i run and
it's not taking into account the range
of motion so
i think what's what's what's happening
and what's happening more and more is
we're building strength
but which not that strength is not
specific for the sport that we want to
do so a sherpa doesn't get up at six
o'clock in the morning and go to the gym
and
pump iron to get good at carrying twice
their body weight yeah what they do
carry twice their body weight and
obviously they have to build up to that
with
with weight but they do the task and if
i watch the east africans when they're
running
largely i see them running and doing
their strength and conditioning on the
move if you run if you do any kind of
activity you're stressing bones
you're tearing muscle fibers yeah and
you're tearing fascia
they will be
rejuvenated re-architect re remolded
rebuilt
during recovery
in this way
in the
current modern approach for strength and
conditioning for particular pursuits
have we just over complicated it have we
thought that we can use strength and
conditioning kit and a hex bar deadlift
and a bunch of elastic bands and stuff
um
in order to create
quicker more appropriate adaptation
whereas we should just be doing more of
the specific pursuit that we're trying
to do ourselves
yeah i think there's definitely a
balance i think there's definitely a
balance but yes i think we are moving i
think there's a tendency to move away
from trying to do the actual movement
beautifully and have in mind that by
doing that movement beautifully you're
breaking down the body and it will
re-architect itself so it's what i would
call darwinian fitness
yep so fitness to perform the task
that's how we evolve so if you want to
throw the javelin you can go in the gym
and get very strong and build a very
powerful body but that but that software
and the hardware it doesn't need to say
that it's good at throwing the javelin
if you go out and throw the javelin 20
times you're going to stress the body
and then the body will rebuild itself
allowing you to do that task better so
i'm sure there's a balance and like as a
coach
my job is to get the athlete thinking
because that's what coaching is i think
if you drill someone you just get them
someone to do something a lot in the
hope they get better at it
and that will probably happen they
probably will get better if they do it a
lot but if they think about how they're
doing it and why they're doing it and
they take ownership of it themselves and
they're very cognitive about it that's
when they maximize their potential and i
think that's what a coach should hope to
do is empower the athlete to take
ownership of that skill not just drill
them lots of times to do it
there's something that i've noticed with
some of my friends i'm friends with a
bunch of different buddies who are uh
elite level crossfitters and
other sports guys as well
there seems to be and i want the ones
that are listening to take this in the
the nicest way possible there seems to
be a good blend
of thoughtfulness
and ignorant stupidity that is important
to be an elite level uh athlete and what
i mean by that is that you need to take
enough of a detailed approach of the
things that you are doing in order to
really be able to cover all of the
different bases
however
the guys i know that overthink
they don't just follow the training plan
sufficiently you know there's a there's
a level of um
insight and intellect that you need to
have
in order to be able to talk yourself out
of your own training plan and some
people can be too smart for their own
good when it comes to training and start
to question the things there is an
amount of uh sort of dunder headed
neanderthal approach that you need where
it's look it's a
it's a 60-minute monostructural workout
just a a like a zone two or a zone three
on a thursday morning it's the most
boring standard workout that i'm ever
gonna do
you just need to go and do it
and yet i've certainly
seen friends in the past who will oh
well if i can if i if i can add some
intervals in i know it says on the
training plan that i'm supposed to do x
so is there um is there a sweet spot
here between the level of detail that
the athlete is supposed to take and then
the amount that they're supposed to kind
of switch that off and then just rely on
the programming too
yeah i absolutely i think there is a
balance and i think that's where you
need that coach to control the overall
thing and to be able to say well look
this is the schedule and this is what we
should be doing yes but
the athlete is the only person on every
run or every wave or throwing every
javelin or fencing or whatever it might
be so they're the ones that can feel
everything they're the ones that have to
make the the split decisions so they
need as much ownership of it as they
possibly can because in any sport the
moment the whistle or the horn goes off
all bets are off it's all on them yeah
everything's changing now from now and
it's the person that can adapt the best
and if you've just been drilled
that's not really conducive to adapting
to something that will almost certainly
happen
how far were our ancestors running in
one go
so
there's my that my go-to person the
person that i love to listen to and i
think makes absolute sense is a guy
called daniel evan professor lieberman i
don't know if you've heard of him or not
a absolutely amazing guy a runner
anthropologist fantastic and you know he
was going out to kenya a long time ago
and looking at how everyone was moving
he's absolutely fantastic so he would
kind of say
really about uh they would run about
maybe a half marathon
at about a four hour marathon pace
so to go back to my original statement
of kipchoge did not break the sub 2 by
running like a hunter-gatherer because
clearly he would have pulled up a lot
earlier yes
there was some running there was quite a
lot of walking yeah and and actually you
know a lot of times sitting and digging
routes and and doing stuff like that so
what we're doing now is taking human
movement and turning it in to human
performance and that's when we have to
adapt our software and our hardware so
it's really interesting because if you
look at humans if you watch a human move
humans are very wonky imbalanced things
a human has a stabilizing leg and it has
a probing leg it has a stabilizing arm
and a manipulating arm because different
sides of the brain well that's how a
human's designed but if you want to
squeeze as much performance of the hue
out of a human as you can you need to
eradicate those and create as much
balance and symmetry in the body as you
can certainly for running different
sports might need different things if
it's a very one-sided sport with one
side of the body so we're taking
and this is why it's a challenge
because we're taking this fish that is
out of water
it's not living in the environment it
was designed to be lived in anymore and
now trying to squeeze incredible
performance out of it to do ever more
amazing things
and that's why we have to really think
about it rather than
just try hard or just do it a lot
so you're saying that persistence
hunting typically
would have pulled up at
the the animal would have overheated
within 13 miles or we would have lost it
on average something like that
yeah so so he said so we would have run
walked so essentially
yeah so we would we would have walked
and run walks and run so yeah but
essentially the idea of persistence
hunting is you you get an animal that's
technically much faster than you over a
shorter distance keep it in and keep it
in eyesight and just keep it moving
because it can't carry water and it
can't sweat so it's going to overheat a
lot quicker than us well i suppose so
the thing that i had in my head because
i've never persistence hunted
surprisingly uh is that
the animal would have just gone and then
gone and you might have lost sight of it
but if i was an animal and i knew that i
didn't have an unlimited gas tank i
would run faster away then i'd turn
around and look and i'd wait and see are
they still coming oh [ __ ] they're still
coming right okay i'll run a bit more
turn around and look so i suppose that
yeah the the um the fact that you would
stop i guess the guys would maybe be
stopping to make sure that the tracks
are going in the right direction if
perhaps they've lost sight of it
directly absolutely they're trackers as
as much as hunters and the exactly
you're not going to be able to keep that
animal in your view the whole time so
their ability to track and understand
almost put their self in the animal's
position where would it run yeah it's
going to steer clear of those trees it's
going towards that whatever
yeah
exactly and the acceleration and the
constant acceleration and deceleration
the stopping and starting of the animal
is incredibly tiring if you go to a
shopping mall or if you go to a
uh a museum and your you're
walking around stopping and looking and
walking and stopping and walking around
and looking that's actually quite tiring
and it's because of that constant
stopping and starting accelerating and
decelerating and stopping you're far
better just rolling along because
i think we've you know even it's
interesting with with certainly with
running is we've built up this
incredibly adversarial relationship with
the ground
because we blame the ground for impact
and we bring impact for injuries
and and so we try and avoid impact and
we've almost become scared of the ground
and at the moment we can sort of the
moment we can step up and walk
across the kitchen floor for the first
time our feet are rammed into shoes to
protect us from the dirty ground and and
so we don't have a great relationship
with the ground and yet when i travel
all around the world and see people that
are growing up in their feet they have a
beautiful relationship with the ground
they're not scared of the ground they
hit the ground beautifully and creates
elastic energy and springs them off
whereas we're trying to spend as much
money as we can to buy very clever
trainers that will claim to protect us
from the ground and and make it yes i
mean this has been
this has been probably the the most
interesting thing to watch as a
non-runner uh over the last few years
it's been the development in shoe
technology and then the subsequent
uh litigation that's come in you know
the the solution that was um
created in order to restrict the amount
of real estate and and technology that
can go into shoes was just to restrict
the stack height right that was the
solution okay you have this amount of
real estate to play with which is where
the sole fits within that
put a rocket booster put 25 carbon
plates do whatever you want but this is
how much you have because if you look at
what kipchoge uh
broke the two-hour marathon barrier in
they're like platform shoes they're
almost comical right they're so big
these huge things so what are your
thoughts about the modern developments
in running shoes and then also what are
your thoughts on minimalist running
shoes or barefoot running shoes
so i think the big thing is that we
should
try not to get so excited about any kind
of shoes and just get really excited
about the human foot because as i said
earlier on the human foot as well as
being able to stand tall the human foot
the very clever human foot is our usp
it creates because everything we're
trying to create with technology is
emulating what the amazing human foot
has
creating stability creating elasticity
spring dissipation of impact
proprioception the foot's amazing at all
of that what we're actually doing is
wrapping that amazing foot in rubber and
then putting some technology on it so
what i would try what i would urge
everybody to do is get excited about
their feet first of all because you
could spend ten thousand dollars on a
pair of trainers it's not going to make
you land with a tripod landing
you could spend twenty thousand pounds
on a pair of trainers it's not going to
make you leave the ground correctly so
you know we can't buy our way out of
trouble it's i think it's easier to
order something and for it to turn up on
the doorstep and we put them on and it's
a magic pair of trainers and now all our
troubles are solved we'd rather do that
and spend 12 weeks learning to move
differently so
so let's not get suckered into that and
let's let's
correct let's create an amazing
human foot that has an amazing
relationship with the ground and then
let's put our foot in a pair of trainers
that helps our foot interact with the
environment it wants to move through
because that's what the trainers should
be doing because clearly our feet can't
we can't run around their feet anymore
we just we just don't have those feet we
can't do it i mean people do in other
parts of the world but we can't we don't
have that foot anymore so
we need to utilize this amazing human
foot but then choose something to put it
in that allows us to stick to rock or
run through mud or whatever it might be
so that the trainers interact with the
environment but we do all the clever
stuff with our foot but that's where
what about minimal issues
well
it would make sense
because we kind of want and we want to
emulate you know how our ancestors move
and move naturally it would make perfect
sense to go to something completely
minimalist because then we'd be there
but again we're not that animal anymore
and so we have to be very very careful
about wearing something minimalist with
zero drop
because that's going to put our achilles
tendon and our calf muscles under a lot
of pressure because
that's not what we've been doing and
suddenly we've got we're running around
we've got two and a half times our body
weight coming back at us because that's
what it is when you're running it's
around two and a half times your body
weight
that can create a huge amount of stress
on the body the body has to adapt to
that and so if we are going to go to
something minimalist we there has to be
a very slow transition yeah
bone remodeling takes 17 weeks so if you
started to move differently today it
takes 17 weeks for the for the bones to
kind of remodel and create density where
where they need to be dense so you know
running around in the park in in a bed
in actual bare feet or something very
minimalist can be good fun um
but be very very careful and again don't
assume that that wearing next to nothing
on your feet will make you move
beautifully as well because it it it
doesn't it doesn't
we have to learn that skill and then
choose a pair of trainers that allow us
to do it a very wide toe cap in the
trainers is good to allow that foot to
splay okay
we tend to hem our feet in with trainers
so a nice wide toe cap is is a good
thing to have you see that in i think a
lot of the shoes that are really
architected to try and have good foot
movement that they they seem to be
almost if you look at them kind of like
flippers you know they're kind of they
look a little bit silly at the end but
presumably that's for the exactly this
reason to give it a bigger toe box so
that you have that room for everything
to move so okay we've sort of spoken
about some of the key principles that
you think contribute to great running
form one of them's been this tripod
landing what's that mean
so tripod landing is essentially when
you when when we land the foot if you
imagine you've got uh so a tripod has
three points to it you've got a point
just sort of underneath the ball of the
big toe a point underneath where the
ball of the little toe would be and then
the heel the calcaneus so you can almost
draw that tripod if you get that tripod
landing
tripods give us stability so we get
instant stability when we land and then
the tripod landing allows the arch of
the foot to work correctly the arch of
the foot gives our foot its strength
that's why we use arches in architecture
and the arch of the foot also creates a
dome effect for the foot if we land on
the tripod landing the dome effect of
the foot works and we use domes in
architecture because we want to spread
weight
so and also if we land on that tripod
landing it means we loaded something
called our plantar fascia correctly
which is a beautiful piece of elastic
that runs along the bottom of the foot
we load that plantar fascia that piece
of elastic that springs us off
and then maybe the most important
subjective but for me i get very excited
about it you've got a quarter of a
million nerve endings on the bottom of
your foot
okay there are more nerves in your feet
than there are your hands
two types of nerve endings extra
receptors the extractors they tell you
how hard you hit the ground and what the
ground felt like was it bumpy soft rocky
moving and then you have proprioceptors
in that nerve network they give you your
spatial awareness and they give you a
perceived rate of exertion how hard
you're trying so every time your foot
lands those quarter of a million nerve
endings are telling you everything you
want to know about your environment as
you're running over it
so if you get the tripod landing you
instantly get all of that information
when you say tripod landing
do you mean
heel and those two ball points
strike at the same time that if you were
to put them onto the floor that they
would be straight down
okay um
what is the most common type of
foot striking mechanism that you see at
the moment
so over the over the last decade i've
worked with over four thousand runners
and many in groups but four thousand
runners where i've videoed them and
worked with them and all the time i'm
coaching i'm also taking data
up until the last 18 months or so
of that four thousand runners that i saw
eighty-four percent of them
he'll strike
so they land on their heel first on a
relatively straight leg
yeah eighty-four percent that's that's
now at sixty-three percent so over the
last 18 months that's changed it it's
got it's changed to 63 so it's coming
down what's happened
that's a really big difference over 18
months what's happened
well
i guess to a large degree a lot of the
people that come and see me have read my
book
there's a selection effect going on
there
yeah you'd have to assume yeah
absolutely okay so some worldwide panda
we didn't realize that covid had
actually changed people's uh foot
strikes
it's not it's not good for breathing but
it's fantastic for your gait and your
cadence
it could be the thing it couldn't be
might not be my book at all that might
be just wishful thinking yeah maybe but
yeah lots more people that are coming
and i work remote i work with remote
video analysis with people on six
continents as well and even and we're
seeing it with them as well so it's
coming down i mean you could argue that
that's that's not good enough you know i
i should i should write a better book it
should be better it should be less than
62. i should up my game a little bit
here but
yeah so that's what you're generally
seeing and that's what we see now and
it's interesting because
a human is designed to land on its heel
when it walks
that's what a human does if you went for
a walk around central park now you would
be landing on a heel on a relatively
straight leg and then rolling through
so what happened a few decades ago now
is
we started running with a walking gate
yeah so the difference between running
and walking is when you walk one foot is
always on the ground when you run you
get air both feet come off the ground at
the same time during the destruction
so we can be running technically because
we're getting air but we're doing it
with a walking gate
jogging i guess
that's how most people would describe it
as jogging so you and listen there's no
such thing as there's no such thing as
bad exercise by the way you know it's
it's good to get out and do stuff um but
essentially what i'm seeing a lot of is
people technically running but with a
walking gate landing on that heel on a
straight leg why
because i think really
because they're running a relatively a
slow pace and so they're not creating
very much air and so there isn't any air
for us to get our legs circling and
cycling underneath us so the leg can
only land out in front of the street
because we've been told one of the big
urban myths of running there are lots of
urban myths of running one is that
impact is bad we're all running around
primarily
well impact turns into elastic energy
and throws you forward one of the other
big urban myths is the air or bounce in
your run is bad is inefficient we are
told to suck ourselves down to the
ground
but if you think of your stride your
stride is a curve it kind of is you
leave the ground you go into the air and
then you land your stride is a curve if
you limit the amount of height you get
in your curve you can only have little
curves
so we're all running around trying to
suck ourselves down to the ground
because we've been told that's efficient
so all we can do is land on a heel on a
straight leg out in front of us which
ironically means we don't dissipate the
impact we've been trying to avoid by
going high
interesting yes so this sort of shuffle
is is a function of people not running
particularly quickly and also trying to
limit the amount of impact that they're
hitting the floor with i see this in
myself you know i i've never had running
analysis done but when i think about the
way that i run i absolutely heel strike
you know i'd think about sort of the
pronation of the foot and about where
i'm striking it but i didn't think that
i was supposed to
supposed to land with that that tripod
position um what about head position
because i know that's another big part
of this
yeah head position is absolutely
fundamental and it's really exciting
because it's fundamental and incredibly
doable to to get it right so if we go
back to how a human was designed an
evolution you know a human was to stand
really designed to stand up very tall
look around for food and make sure that
they didn't become food so the head
belongs
up with the eye line on the horizon
essentially
and there are three so it's if
we've talked about this elastic
connective fascia this tissue that runs
continuously from our toes up into our
skull we need our head up eye line on
the horizon because that creates
beautiful tension then in our elastic
system
also your inner ear your vestibular area
your inner ear that's where your balance
and spatial awareness comes from so the
head really needs to be up where it was
designed to be for that balance and
spatial awareness to be right if it's
down then that's a problem
and mo walking around with mobile phones
and just sitting looking at mobile
phones we're spending so much of our
time now with our head down
huge amounts what's the difference in
weight between your head when it's up
and your head when it's leaning over so
are your pounds or a kilo who what are
we going to kilos kilos so your head the
human head weighs
some of that weight slightly more than
others but the human head weighs around
about five kilos okay
when it's
eye line on the horizon for every inch
forward it comes forward
it weighs another five kilos so if your
head is three inches down you've now got
a 20 kilo head now actually the head
itself doesn't get heavier it's it's a
it's a moments thing in physics it's
essentially it's spread so it's actually
the spot the the upper neck and the
spine that is now taking that quadruple
weight yeah
and and so and i'll tell you what's
really been interesting is
with you know the pandemic we've had
over the last couple of years and people
are wearing masks of course
actually to see your phone because the
mask restricts your view people are
heads are coming down even further so
instead of putting the phone up in front
of our faces actually we crane our head
even more to allow oh yeah of course
so when we talk we were joking earlier
on about the pandemic and does it make
you land on a tripod and all of this
sort of stuff well actually
one of the offsets from this which is
pretty intangible at the moment but
people's head positions are
changing quite substantially another
probably another five kilos on the the
the distribution weighted of your head
because of a mask
i can see it
you can see it even though the mask
weighs
three grams
the impact of the mask is causing you
that is so interesting
what about um
talk to me about stride length stride
length and cadence and turnover and
stuff like that
so so yeah so cadence
we've all come we've all got pretty
obsessed with cadence over the years i
think biggest cadence is the first one
the first running dynamic that we could
monitor and and so it's the one that the
technology joined in with first and so
for anybody listening who doesn't know
what cadence is it's essentially how
many times our feet hit the ground in a
minute and the holy grail of cadence has
always been talked about as being 180.
so we are told that when we run around
we should be hitting the ground 180
times a minute three times a second yeah
yeah absolutely
now
and that's true as it goes but not for
the reason
we've been told
generally so remember i said 84 of those
4 000 runners were heel striking on a
straight leg and that's now gone down to
62
well
the average cadence for those people was
163
okay
so the average runner if there is such a
thing is running around 163 cadence
landing on a heel on a straight leg and
we don't want that so what started to
happen was coaches would get metronomes
and put a metronome on to somebody or
just get them running at a cadence of
180. so they speed their cadence up from
163 on average to 180 which meant that
their feet would turn over quicker and
land more underneath them no longer on a
heel
so that sounds like
a good antidote but it's a bit a little
bit like sticking a plaster over a
fracture because you've tricked the
person into not heel striking anymore
you haven't changed their gaits you
haven't really changed anything you just
made them have stride length of a mouse
so that yeah people land underneath them
but the moment they try and run fast
again or open their stride they're just
going to go back to landing on a hill on
australia
so for anybody listening out there who's
monitoring their cadence do not let
cadence dictate your form
cadence isn't about correcting your form
the reason we should get excited about
cadence is and actually the figure
should be between i believe one seven
five and one eight five that's that's
what the cadence we should be looking
for so it isn't it doesn't have to be
180 it can be between 175 and 185
because when you're running when your
foot hits the ground
as i said earlier you have about two and
a half times your body weight coming
back at you that impact coming back into
your body creates a load of elastic
energy in the body
and that elastic energy has a frequency
everything has a frequency
a frequency of creation store and
release of elastic energy so the foot
hits the ground bang you've created the
elastic energy yeah and softens as you
pass over the foot it stores it and then
as the foot leaves the ground the
elastic energy fires
amazing you've created the energy from
nothing you store it and then it leaves
with you as you leave the ground but
only if you run a cadence which syncs in
with that elastic frequency
and that's what that 175 to 185 is so if
you went out and ran around central park
at a 180 cadence you can be as confident
as we can be and there need to be more
research on this but as confident as we
can be that every time you hit the
ground you create elastic energy you
store it as you move through the sky and
then yeah
you off with a with a burst of elastic
energy
so that's really exciting
you would want that you wouldn't want to
be out of sync of that so that's why
cadence is important what should people
do with their arms and their shoulders
and their hands this is something that
i've never had any idea what i'm
supposed to be doing yeah so i think
when we run
you know if you if you if you pulled a
hundred people in and said you know what
how do you run what do you do everyone
would say you run with your legs you
know you use you use your legs to run
well
you know
running is a full body
exercise every single piece of your body
is moving when you run we have no
dividing lines in our body only
connecting lines
and actually because of our very
dexterous hands because we do everything
with our hands and our arms they're
closer to our brain than our legs we can
see them i think it's fair to say we
have a better relationship with these
than we do our legs yes so what that
means is in movement in dynamic movement
especially in running is the arms are
incredibly dominant over the legs
so your kinetic movement is such that
your right arm and your left leg move
together and your left arm and your
right leg move together that's the way
it is but these very very clever things
are telling our not very bright legs
what to do so if you're running around
with your legs
carrying your arms and not doing much
with them because you can't really leave
them at home but you don't want to waste
any energy with them because you want to
save the energy for your legs the arms
just not doing much ascending very very
difficult messages for the legs to have
to cope with
so kip sang capruto keep choking they
will tell me they're wrong with their
arms yeah they their arms to run
so the arm swing we're looking for is a
very very relaxed shoulder
and all the dynamic movement is done
with the elbow
and always to the rear so the arm is
driving constantly
to the rear
very relaxed shoulder arm movement to
the rear because that's then telling the
leg to land underneath you and come out
behind you
as well
so you're not pushing the arm forward
correct you pull the arm back you allow
it to pendulum through to the front and
then you pull back and then you pull
back you never see any air really here
everything is to the rear to the rear to
the rear oh so are you saying are you
saying that your um
your upper arm
wouldn't ever go much past sort of 90
degrees
correct oh so it's even more than that
yeah okay yeah yeah you because if your
very clever right arm drives forward
you're not very bright left leg is going
to follow it and you're going to land on
that heel on a straight leg
so many of those 84 of those 4 000
runners that heel striking are doing it
because their arms are coming out in
front of them am i right in thinking
that by having this slightly more um
posterior focused
arm movement that it's going to force us
into a more open chest and a more
upright posture doesn't hurt absolutely
right if you're thinking about this i
talk about this center line in your body
which is an imaginary line that runs
from your belly button up through the
abdomen up through the chest to the top
of the head when you're running you open
up that center line and put a bow into
that center line that gets your upper
body over your center of gravity it puts
more surface area into your elastic
system it brings your hips forward and
gets a nice neutral pelvis and then the
arms driving to the rear just completes
that beautiful position you're
absolutely right what about hands are
hands
fists open
whatever's comfortable
no this is exciting so hands so
we want balance and symmetry in our arms
because our arms are dominant over our
legs and running is all about balance
and symmetry in the body so if you want
balance and symmetry in your arms your
hands must do exactly the same thing if
you run with one hand open and one thumb
up the
stop and the thumb will go up you know
the hands the hands then the arms off in
crazy positions
so
what i love to see is if you have your
index finger
onto your thumb like so and then the
other three fingers just run a lot
that's it perfect so you would run like
that
if you do that both hands are completely
symmetrical you know that they are
your fingertip your index finger on your
thumb is the perfect tension sensor for
your body
if you squeeze those fingertips you can
feel the tension going up your arm and
sweeping through your body if your
fingertips are soft you know the arm is
soft
so when you're running and muscle
tension is an athlete's nemesis we want
elastic tension but not muscle tension
but when we're running if our fingertips
are soft we know
that the upper body is relaxed if these
are tense
we know the tension is sweeping through
like a canary in the coal mine
completely completely and what also
happens is
your uh
wrist
your elbow and your shoulder those
joints have tendons and ligaments in
those joints that are holding the joints
together and holding muscle to bone they
do that job but the tendons and
ligaments also
propriocept their position in space so
just like the proprioceptors on the
bottom of your foot the proprioceptors
in your joints are giving your dark
silent skull a position of your arm as
you move
if your fingertips are touching you lock
in that proprioception
better
so you have a better spatial awareness
of your arms if your fingertips are
touching they're also great tension
sensors and they do something completely
symmetrical
that can honestly be a game changer for
runners
i like it i like it what about breathing
yeah breathing's good definitely
breathing is good yep i tried i've been
a fan for all my life
that's not it so
deep rhythmic breathing
into the belly to allow the diaphragm to
be able to do the work if we breathe
fast and shallow we tend to breathe into
our chest and that actually we have to
use muscles to do the breathing and
the very oxygen you're getting in by
breathing in is a lot of that's going to
the muscles to actually do the job so
we don't want to
we often
we often let the movement of our arms
and legs dictate our breathing yeah
especially when we're trying to up our
cadence in that that's one often it can
be a challenge to up our cadence because
our breathing wants to get faster to go
with this increased cadence that we're
looking for
so
we
we don't want to completely disassociate
the breathing from our movement of our
arms and necks because i think it you
know it should be a whole thing
but i think
what we should try and aim for and
there's no one size that fits all here
but what i think we should try and aim
for is
to be able to breathe in for three foot
fours and breathe out for three foot
fours
that way that's going to slow the
breathing down it's still going to keep
it in harmony with the movement because
you want the whole thing to try and be
together the breathing the movement
together we must get our breathing right
because if good running is about
relaxation and
rhythm
in the body we need that in our
breathing if we're fighting for air
we're not going to move with relaxation
and rhythm in our body are we
yeah it's it's an interesting one is
there something
have you found that it's more optimal
for people to either end or begin a
breath mid-stride or as they strike
never thought about it yeah never
thought about i haven't no i wouldn't i
wouldn't drill that that i wouldn't got
to be this is where you think are we
overthinking this because it's
difficult enough if your listeners go
out tomorrow and try this it's difficult
enough to be able to count three in as
your as your
thumb and the index finger together as
they've got that position yeah i mean
it's everything with this is so slow to
introduce i'm going to guess is there a
process that you go through do you
advise people to say okay so if you're
running over the next x number of
sessions or x number of weeks we're
going to focus on
hands and shoulders then after maybe
someone's introduced that for a period
of time then we're going to look at
cadence then we're going to look at
breathing then we're going you know
trying to add too much in at once is
going to end up with nothing being done
have you got a protocol for how people
can introduce things bit by bit yeah
definitely and so one of the big things
for everybody to think about here is
that if you go out and start changing
your movement tomorrow you are not
creating new muscle memory we talk about
muscle memory all the time and we assume
that we're teaching a muscle to do a new
trick we're not muscles don't really
remember anything what we're doing is
rewriting our software we're telling
we're changing our software which then
tells the muscle what to do so changing
your movement is definitely a cognitive
thing yeah you're re-writing this that's
quite exciting because i think it makes
it it makes it very doable we have to
understand the challenge to be able to
do it so if you went out for a run let's
say you went out for a five mile run
tomorrow if the first mile you ran
beautifully
but the last four work great then
actually you're gonna you're gonna
retain the software of the the not great
four
start to change your movement the good
movement has got to outweigh
the the not so good movement so that's
the first thing to think about and so
that probably means for some people to
do go for that little and often approach
rather than just long runs yeah so
you know if you were running 30 miles a
week
in three runs you might want to run 30
miles a week but in five or six runs so
half the distance and just do it twice
as often because you're focusing more on
the biomechanics yeah okay okay exactly
and are you doing
would you say one
do you partition off what you're
focusing on you know for this period of
time we're focusing on one thing
yeah so i think the first thing to
really you know that that foot being the
interface between you and the ground
it's got to get that interface right
like everything else if the interface
isn't good everything behind it doesn't
really work so
to first port of all is to really
practice landing that foot well and
leaving the ground well and then start
to work up the body and yeah just pick
them
it's interesting it all sounds like even
the stuff we're talking about well i've
got to go out i can't think about all of
those things yeah the first time you
jump in a car you have to think about
the clutch and the gears and the an
indicator and steering and you think i
can't do it i can't do it it's not long
before you can do all of that and chat
and you know so what sensory overload at
first actually you get very good at
building those motor skills but yeah in
the early stages little often pick
something work on it when you feel
you've got it add another skill to it
how is it that we've got through an
entire conversation about people being
good at running and we haven't spoken
about lactate threshold or vo2 max or
hrv or any of that stuff
well
i mean it's really interesting i mean
yeah we've done well um
i'm i've got a research project going on
with the university of east london at
the moment and that that research
project is uh 20 sensors that go all
over the body this is running outside
nothing on a trigger i always work
outside i think that's another reason
why the indiana jones thinks it's only
ever research coach analyzed outside so
we've got this 27 20 sensors that go all
over the body that create 3d models of
people running outside but we're also
collecting mobile gases as well so co2
levels oxygen levels
and what we're seeing even now in the
early stages is that our running economy
can be better by up to 30 just by
changing the way that you move now you'd
have to work pretty hard to get your vo2
max up just a little bit or your lactate
threshold up a little bit 30
and that's actually unpracticed that's
when they're not good at it if they go
away and practice so the gains are huge
and
when i first started kenya in ethiopia
and when the athletes used to come over
to europe to race they would come
through heathrow and i would kind of
gather them up take them to the
university and we'd get them on um sort
of treadmills and they'd be putting all
sorts of stuff on them and looking at
their lactate thresholds vo2 maxes and
they were always fantastic but what was
always off the scale was their economy
yeah so the economy and movement it's
good to build a big engine but if you
can build a big engine and take the toll
of what that engine's got to do down by
using elastic energy by using gravity by
using other things other than thirsty
muscles you don't need such a massive
engine
love it shane benzie ladies and
gentlemen if people want to keep up to
date with what you do where should they
go
uh so um so it's running reborn so
runningreborn.com you'll find me there
and everything that i do and everything
i'm getting up to will be there and uh
yeah i'd be great to see you thanks
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace